It's great to welcome back to the program,
our old friend Bill Chere, contributing editor
to Politico magazine, contributor to Real
Clear Politics, and an ardent follower of
the ins and outs of election years in particular.
Although, you know, you're not just an election
year guy.
You're in.
Year in, year out.
But things get more interesting and.
I have many, many years, David.
Yes, of course.
So, I mean, listen, just to start with.
What is the trajectory for the next five and
a half months?
It's like, is this election going to happen
in person?
Is it going to be vote by mail?
Will it depend on state by state?
People are talking about Trump will try to
delay it, but he will fail it.
I just have no idea how to even think of the
next five and a half months.
Well, you can't delay it.
He does have the power to delay it.
Congress would never agree to delay it.
That won't happen to the extent we're voting
by mail.
Probably could be pretty patchwork state by
state.
Some states would do a better job and get
ahead of the curve.
Some states will drag their feet.
And you know what that means at the end of
the day is hard to project.
And as far as to what extent this whole pandemic
is going to matter.
You know, it's obviously a big wildcard.
But consider this.
We are in May.
We've already had in 2020 an impeachment,
a ongoing pandemic and economic collapse and
a sexual assault allegation at the Democratic
nominee presumptive as well.
Not to mention, of course, the past allegations
to the current president and the numbers haven't
moved very much.
Joe Biden has had a fairly stable lead in
the Real Clear Politics average, generally
between five and seven.
Now, just on this past Friday, in a tick down
to 4.4, that might be a little statistical
noise or could be a two week.
So torrid coverage, as you know, brought down
a little bit.
But you go back to the fall cities to September
of twenty nineteen.
Biden has never been below four in the in
his average lead in RCP.
And that is different than Hillary Clinton
will get.
People keep saying, oh, Hillary was ahead
in the polls.
So as Biden, you can't trust that.
Look, things can change.
I'm not saying Biden is a lock, but their
numbers are different.
Hillary had dipped several times going below
for into a near tie or an actual tie.
Couple of times, even slightly behind.
Between September 2015 and Election Day and
in May of twenty sixteen, she had a big dip.
She.
So you're saying Biden.
Biden was worse than Hillary in April?
Yeah.
Hillary was peaking in April.
April was when she was C.l.A.
She was putting Birdie away and there were
some buyer's remorse on Trump.
And Cruz is winning some primaries.
May was win, but Trump locked it down.
Bernie is still dogging Hillary and the FBI
investigation on the email servers was really
cranking up.
And she went from, you know, nine points to
a tie by the end of the month.
Now, she got she bounced back up.
She was volatile.
She was bouncing up and down now, like every
week.
But some Biden has not done that much at all.
He had a narrowing with Barrès HMA at the
turn of the year, which got him down to four,
moved back up into five and seven.
Now he's a little closer to four as of today.
But it's not like Terry.
It is becoming, you know, omnipresent in the
media.
So I wouldn't think that would keep following
the way Hillary did with the email server
investigation.
Yeah, I want to talk about the terrorist thing
in a moment now.
One of the things in 2016, you hear this talking
point, the polls were just wrong.
Now, I think it's important when we look at
that to say in terms of the popular vote,
the polls were essentially correct.
Of course, we have an electoral college system
and you can find three states where about
seventy five thousand votes push the Electoral
College over to Trump.
That to me seems I mean, I know there's these
hypotheticals where you could win the Electoral
College with 27 percent of the popular vote.
We've never seen that.
And it would have to be a crazy situation.
In practice is three points of popular vote
difference, roughly the most that could still
see the Electoral College go the other way.
And to put it a different way.
If Biden wins the popular vote by 5.
Wouldn't it be incredibly like one in a million
that he would lose the Electoral College?
I mean, some of our better, better data journalists
like Dave Washerwomen, like Nate Cohn or earlier
fears earlier this year or late last year,
we're making the case that Trump could win
by five points.
Trump could lose popular vote by 5 points
or more.
Yes, I'd still win the Electoral College.
There are ways that can happen based on how
the demographics play out.
However, those projections were made before
we saw Biden's demographics.
Biden's demographics are not Hillary's demographics.
Biden does better, much better with seniors
than Hillary did and Obama did.
You look at Hillary and Obama's numbers generationally.
It's a diagonal line downward.
The older you get, the less democratic you
are.
Biden's kind of a V.
But it gets kind of soft around middle age,
around Gen X and in early boomers and they
comes back up with 65 and over.
And so that may make a difference in states
with senior populations like Florida, like
our zone.
So what we see today, at least when we see
Biden around four to seven in most polls,
Monmouth was nine.
That was kind of high end.
CNBC was three.
There was one tie, which was the Investor's
Business Daily, but generally five to seven
state polls in this same period.
Very good for Biden.
Winning in Florida, winning an hour zone to
winning in the industrial Midwest was even
one where he was even up in Texas along with
a tie.
So it's not good.
Not a lock.
These are not like massive leads that can't
evaporate based on circumstances in the future.
But you are seeing Bida doing well in the
swing states while winning in the popular
vote by around 5 or so.
So a terror read.
My sense of this situation is there cannot
possibly be what we would call a conclusive
investigation into the allegations said.
I'm going to talk more about this on the program
tomorrow.
But to not do my segment tomorrow.
Now, the gist of it is you've got a he said
she said situation.
The complaint that Tara Reid says she filed
but doesn't mention sexual assault, she doesn't
have a copy of.
And it's not clear what the date is.
So I guess what I'm saying is, without criticizing
or even evaluating the truth of the claims,
there's not enough to conclusively determine
what happened.
And thus something I don't know what that
something is.
I just think there's a lot of people wanting
something conclusive which they're never going
to get.
What's your sense of it?
Well, I wouldn't put myself in the position
of being the adjudicator.
What's true?
What's not?
Of course.
Right.
And that's the thing.
I don't think we're going to be able to.
Let me just try to talk about this in the
terms of, I think the reaction amongst Democrats.
Yes.
And the reaction in the media.
OK.
Biden gave a response a week plus ago that
went over well with elected Democrats.
You did not see any elected Democrats criticize
him.
You didn't see anyone say, take me off the
running for V.P..
You didn't see the endorsement.
Stop coming.
You saw Democrats repeat his messages.
He gave a statement which other Democrats
felt comfortable echoing.
Democrats don't always do that.
That's a that's a significant thing.
So, number one, he kept his party in line
with that.
Number two, I think T.R.
Reid has made some PR mistakes.
Again, this is not a there's not a bear on
whether it's true or not.
You're right.
You can be.
You could be telling the truth.
I mean, PR mistakes.
But I think it was a mistake to not respond
to Biden quickly.
You know, she canceled on FOX.
She canceled on CNN.
So.
And so that created a three or four day period
where some of media coverage were poking holes
in the story and she wasn't responding.
And even though this might have gotten wide,
pick up the vox recounting of what T.R.
Reid said, they're actually true.
There was an AP story and as VOCs story that
got into what she said in twenty nineteen
to reporters that wasn't published at the
time.
And contrasting that with what was said today
and not just her, but also one of her anonymous
corroborate is.
And between 19, substance and tone was not
sexual.
You know what?
I wasn't scared by him.
He wasn't going to take me in a room, wasn't
that kind of vibe.
The friends saying that he never kissed her.
It just has a totally different tone and context
to what was being said today.
And clearly, that's had residents in media
circles as well as Democratic circles, where
they're not as inclined to take what Tara
Reid is saying, a straight face value without
adding in these mitigating elements.
So what you find is, Megan Kelly, a decision
to do a, you know, kind of a big name, but
not on a TV platform, on an online platform.
You didn't see, like if she did a CNN exclusive
that gets looped on CNN all day long.
Yeah.
You know, whatever whatever you think of the
veracity of it, it just gets repeated, repeated,
repeated.
You do better.
You discuss it.
That didn't happen with Megan Kelly.
All this stuff about Biden's side of the story
and the questions of Toreach story that had
time to settle and that did not get reversed
by the Bacon Kelly interview.
Is your sense that in six weeks this will
be a bigger part of the race or a smaller
part of the race?
It's going to be, I think, largely a non-factor
unless another shoe drops.
I mean, who could have known that she had
a neighbor that she spoke to in 1996?
You know, come out of nowhere.
You know, somebody that happens.
Sure, things could change.
But of course, someone accuses him of making
a verbal sexual harassment to a 14 year old
as debunked in 24 hours.
So what comes out of the woodwork and doesn't
hold up to scrutiny?
You know, that's those are things that are
going to matter whether this keeps going.
Now, I could see, regardless of what happens
going forward, Donald Trump doing social media
stuff, targeting younger people, targeting
women, trying to plant seeds of doubt.
You know, salmiya under the radar.
See if you can hurt by an on the margins,
you do the stuff with Hillary.
You know, very successfully.
But that was a close race.
That stuff works at a close race.
It's not a close race.
I don't know that stuff matters.
So before the pandemic really got going, I
had kind of a sense that in large part, November
would be a lot about the perception of the
state of the economy.
That's not any particularly unique insight.
That's it would just it would just be that
as it often is.
And that's what made me think that polling
aside, it was going to be very, very difficult
to remove Donald Trump in November with the
completely failed handling of the pandemic.
I started to think maybe this is going to
affect the trajectory now.
Political scientist Rachel Betook offer a
couple weeks ago said she doesn't really think
that that's going to make a difference.
And I want to try to pass through the idea
of maybe the handling of the pandemic itself
is baked in in the sense that Trump's followers
think he's doing fine with it.
And a whole bunch of other people don't believe
that he's handled it well, but that that's
not necessarily going to change too many votes.
But isn't that directly linked to the economy
at this point?
In the sense that isn't the perception of
the economy in October or November going to
relate directly to what happens with the virus?
Sure.
And you know, I like Rachel better coffer
a lot.
I've taught she's been a source all of my
pieces.
I think she's great.
I generally agree in a more a political science
view than perhaps a campaign operative view
of political science.
Is generally look at the fundamentals.
The stuff the campaigns do tends to not have
that much impact at the end of the day, at
best on the margins.
I generally subscribe to that, but this is
a bit uncharted territory.
For example, a political scientist might say.
Second quarter GDP is highly determinative
of the outcome.
If you're on the rise, people feel good about
the economy.
You know, GDP numbers tend to kind of filter
through over time.
So how you how it feels on the ground, you
know, you don't feel it right away.
So what happened the second quarter you'll
feel by election day.
And that's why that tends to have a correlation.
And so if you're on a downward trend in the
second quarter, even if things are statistically
picking up, I'd remember you don't feel it
yet.
Like George Bush in 1992.
And so that doesn't help you.
Let's explore that just briefly, because the
timing so people understand second quarter's
April, May, June.
It typically takes about 35 days to get the
numbers.
So we would know around August 5th or 10th.
I think what the second quarter GDP numbers
were, if they are indeed minus 20, as some
are predicting.
You're talking about a period starting in
mid-August, which is actually much closer
to the election that than the second quarter
itself.
It would it would seem highly likely that
second quarter GDP will be disasterous.
Yeah.
As you might punch that into a model and say
it's a done deal where I would pause it, say
this is a little different than your usual
recession or depression.
Yes, maybe the virus lifts by September and
people start shopping more robustly in October.
And even though these statistics haven't caught
up to that, you're feeling better and your
opinion of Trump is better now.
I'm not saying I think that's a high probability
probability scenario.
I think it's much more likely this virus doesn't
go away at all.
And we're still stuck in our homes for an
extended period of time.
Yeah, but that's the kind of thing that I
can't say with certainty.
The bottom line is, do you feel you're at
war?
We're getting better.
We're getting worse.
And I'm not sure we can use current numbers
to know that because this is such a highly
unusual situation.
Yeah, my my message to my audience has simply
been, I don't care what state you vote in.
I don't care what the polls say.
I don't care what the past tells us about
what happens when the economy is bad.
Improving, whatever.
We just really don't know.
And if you care about removing Donald Trump,
just make sure that you vote and get 10 other
people to vote.
However, you can do it because it's just so
unpredictable.
Well, that's right.
Now.
And any time an election is going to be close,
that kind of geo TV can really matter.
Right.
You know, if you're Wisconsin and Michigan
sends me, they came down to a handful of votes.
One campaign has been a little bit better
than the other.
Yeah.
That changed the whole election.
Now, if we're in a situation where the country's
we decided this truck, they did not work.
That was a bad idea.
His failed a multitude of ways.
And Biden's up by seven points or whatever.
You know, getting five more your friends.
Doesn't matter.
Not sure, I'd say.
I don't think you should do it.
Let's say you should take it.
Take a nap on Election Day.
But I think Super Tuesday is relevant here.
I mean, I talked with us in a Politico article
today.
Super Tuesday was this fantastic real time
poly sci experiment.
What's more important is it paid media?
Who owns the airwaves?
Is it a ground game which is often fueled
by a lot of online organizing these days,
or is it free media?
Michael Bloomberg owned pay media.
He just crushed paid media up and down, flooded
the airwaves.
Bernie had the ground game.
He had the online.
He had he had the door knocking.
He had the small donor arm.
He had all that stuff.
Biden was broke.
It had new field offices.
There were states he didn't even visit.
But his free media from Saturday to Tuesday
was as golden as it's ever been.
And it wasn't just that it was good.
It was communicating a message that Democrats
wanted to hear who is electable, who is going
to govern in a sound and sane way, who's going
to unify the party?
That all came together in that 72 hour period.
And any one going away with some endorsements
in that in that period as well.
But but it's not like people did.
I mean, most endorsements don't matter.
Right.
You know, Al Gore did not save Howard Dean.
Correct.
The endorsements communicated a message.
Yeah.
It was a very narrow scenario where they actually
made a difference.
Yes.
Because it's all like P. A judge had that
many votes to give that club a charade, that
many votes to give or better would get that
many votes to give.
But there were people from different slices
of the party, although generally on the moderate
side of things saying, hey, if you if you're
not on for evolution, if you if you want a
more moderate, pragmatic choice, you could
unify the part of the country.
You have one option.
And it's not Michael Bloomberg.
It's not me, Pete.
It's not me, Amy.
It's this guy.
And there were enough Democrats who liked
that message to cut consolidate around him
without the benefit of a strong campaign apparatus.
So if the message in November is Trump is
doing a terrible job and Biden is a sane,
competent alternative, you're not going need
massive digital operations or fantastic advertising
to win the election.
It's just going to be baked in the fundamental
dynamics of the electorate.
Bill Share, contributing editor to Politico
magazine, contributor to Real Clear Politics.
We'll link to his latest article that he referred
to.
Bill, always a pleasure having you on.
Good to talk to you as well.
Take care.